some studies say that up to like 20 25  of men are raising a kid that's not  theirs oh [ __ ] okay yeah one one in  four let's just say 20 on the low end  okay okay this is not this is in 2022.  if a girl does that knowingly or knowing  that there is a chance that that kid is  not his should she face prison time for  every year that that man wasted raising  a kid that wasn't his straight gunshots  that's crazy  okay yes yes or no  no  come on okay he wasted time resources  money she should waste the same let's  make it equal is at least a fraud case  you know what i'm saying yeah  it's fraud okay  so if he got her 16 years yeah and he  was raising yeah and she had been doing  fraud it would probably be four years  yesterday i think it goes under under  fraud okay